for talks and the first will be given by
Adam clearance from university silence
and to be about efficient algorithms for
our player robust regression thank you
switch to me on like that okay thanks to
Elias and the rest of the organizers for
inviting me to the workshop it's a great
workshop Thank You Ilyas yeah
continuing on the theme of talks from
this morning I'm going to talk about
efficient algorithms for a supervised
learning problem this one may be the
most basic of supervised learning
problems just ordinary regression and I
should say this is joint work with
profession ari will be joining CMU and
Raghu mecha is a professor at UCLA
so as I was saying you're sort of most
basic supervised learning problem
ordinary least-squares regression you
have a set of data points you want to
find the best fitting line with respect
to square loss and there are you know
various models that we could consider
for this problem one is the what I would
call the realizable model where your
values Y are actually some linear
function of your of area its X and
there's another model called the
probabilistic concept model where you
assume that the conditional mean
function is actually some linear
function of W inner product X and
typically throughout the talk I'll write
L star when I want refer to the best
fitting line with respect to square loss
in this scenario so we're going to
consider a problem that's more difficult
just a little bit more difficult I'm
going to work in what I would call the
agnostic model of learning and here the
setup is that we have some Joint
Distribution D on R to the D cross 0 1
so I'm going to assume that all of your
labels are coming from some bounded set
0 1 and then because the scenario is not
realizable I'm going to define this
quantity called opt which is the error
the square loss error for the best
fitting linear function W and then we're
going to be given draws s from some
training set and I just want to you know
and what is your goal your goal is to
output some so let's see if my writing
works so you want to out no no
so you want to output some L such that
the square loss
well is something like opt plus epsilon
so you know the the error of the
best-fitting linear function is opt you
want to output some other linear
function whose square loss is very close
to opt and what you're given are draws
IIED draws from this distribution D and
as you know many of you know this
problem is actually solvable in
polynomial time by first applying any
efficient algorithm for least squares
regression we could run gradient descent
over your sample you can compute the SVD
whatever you'd like to do and then
applying an appropriate generalization
bound because what we really want to do
is come up with a linear function whose
square loss with respect to future draws
and the distribution is within epsilon
of optimal I'm sorry to go over this you
know super basic problem but actually as
an anecdote Ravi Khanna and speaking
after me and I remember when I took his
undergraduate automata Theory class I
think I was a senior at the time can I
tell the do I have time to tell this
anecdote ok so when I was a senior at
the time that Carnegie Mellon you know
we had all taken algorithms and actually
a bunch of us had taken you know
graduate computational complexity we
were very ambitious sort of naive
undergrad and so then we took Robby's
course which was an undergrad course in
a Tom about theory and he lectured to us
about NP completeness and I remember he
started you know just defining and P
completeness and reductions and I think
someone sitting next to me it was like
yeah we've seen all this before and then
as if on cue Ravi was like I know you've
probably seen this before but it's never
bad to see things like twice and then
actually accrue to me while I was doing
it that like I really didn't understand
completeness and then I actually needed
to see it another time
so this is not to say that you don't
understand ordinary least-squares
regression and all I mean to say that I
don't feel bad about the finding again
what if like Dee has some very low
probability some factor where X is
gigantic
yeah I'm bounding everything okay so
this is not really actually you don't
need to worry about X being gigantic you
need to worry about the label being
gigantic X is gigantic then you might be
forced to give up will be a W that's
perpendicular to that gigantic actors
I'm also bounding like you know the
domain of the optimal weight vector that
that's not the fact that you just if
there's some low probability of there
being a tremendously large X then even
if W is absolute value you want to get
better be almost orthogonal to that of X
the first month of ethics what sends
otherwise that poster the thing yeah it
depends on my equation you want if you
are happy with they mentioned dependent
and as long as the domain with respect
which is founded and it's not a problem
fine yeah her place are to the d by 0 1
to the deer's actually you need
something weaker than that for example
if I can bound like the covariance of I
think of everything is bounded well okay
so the set up here still going with the
set up is so now I'm going to introduce
noise to the problem so my training set
s is M draws x1 y1 x2 y2 XM ym and each
X I Y I citizen 0 1 so now I'm going to
allow an adversary to come and corrupt
1/8 a fraction of the points in s
however he/she wants and I'm gonna call
this corrupted set u and all that I'm
gonna require is that the size of you
intersect s divided by the size of s
- ADA okay so the adversary can actually
corrupt an ADA fraction of points
however he wants and this is more
general than say the hueber
contamination model and the dream result
would be that even given samples that
have been corrupted I'm still able to
output a linear function L that has air
approximately opt + epsilon with respect
to the distribution from which these
samples were drawn so is that the dream
result is clear
so we're going to do something like this
we are going to give there's been some
contemporaneous work that I'll mention
on the next slide but as far as I could
tell or we were aware there were
actually no results along these lines so
we sort of give the first efficient
algorithms for solving this problem
we're not going to get a plus epsilon
we'll get something sort of like a plus
epsilon we also proved that in general
if you don't take an assumption on the
marginal distribution on X that it's
impossible to get this dream result it's
impossible to solve this problem and
like I said as far as we were aware even
exponential time algorithms that
satisfied these properties were known
okay so the so informally what do we
actually do we come up with a polynomial
time algorithm that will output some
linear function l and the square loss of
L remember we wanted off two plus
Epsilon instead we're going to get one
plus order square root ADA times opt
plus order square root of ADA times this
term right here which is slightly
annoying but you can actually improve
this bound and put an L star there so at
least in the case where you have a
realizable model or even when the
conditional mean function is equal to L
star in a product X this term will go to
0 and this term opt will be 0 and you'll
actually be able to recover the original
linear function okay but for so for kind
of simpler models where you assume say
realizability will actually be able to
recover will sort of get the dream
result that we wanted and for these more
general models the agnostic setting will
get something like a plus Epsilon
with these factors one plus square root
of ADA sitting there and we'll also need
will also need as I mentioned
assumptions on the distribution on the
marginal distribution
uh next but as I mentioned these
assumptions are unavoidable because if
you don't take one the problem is
impossible
and I guess I also want to mention
there's been a lot of independent
concurrent work on this problem there's
a paper by dykey nickel Ilya stacking up
dykey necklace Kong and Stewart they
considered the case when X is a
spherical Gaussian is that right Ilyas
when the marginal distribution of X is a
Gaussian okay for Gaussian and then
there's this
dico necklace come off Kane Lee Stewart
Steinhardt paper that contains this
sever algorithm that also will sort of
solve this problem and there was some
work by some people at CMU Prasad's
oogle of Balakrishna and ravi kumar let
me just point out what distinguishes the
results in this paper from these
contemporaneous works and that is that
we were concerned about was sort of this
agnostic setting where i don't assume
that anything's realizable and we wanted
to put as few assumptions as possible on
the distribution so I think that our
results are sort of the most general
though they don't get the sharpest
bounds and we're also going to use a
different set of techniques some of
which were described by Gerry in the
morning talk sum of squares and all I'll
talk about that a little bit yes I did
and it is yes so we have examples I'll
talk about it later in the talk
okay so forget about computation for a
second here's a naive strategy that you
might employ to try and solve this
problem
okay so again s is the original training
set that you get and s prime is the
corrupted training set okay so remember
I said even a brute-force search
algorithm wasn't known so why not try
brute force search literally take all
possible subsets besides one - ADA times
the size of s and then for each one of
those subsets use ordinary least-squares
to that subset to come up with some
linear function and output that w that
linear function that you get that has
the minimal square loss over all of
these subsets okay one nice thing about
this strategy is that certainly one of
the subsets that you try will be the
truly uncorrupted subset so one of the
linear functions that you get is
actually going to be the optimal linear
function but the problem is that an
adversary could make your set strange in
such a way that you actually find some
other linear function whose square loss
is even smaller on this corrupted
training set but it doesn't generalize
well with respect to the original
distribution so you end up taking the
smallest one with minimal square loss
and then you fail that's that's really
the problem with this algorithm
nevertheless you can actually prove that
this will succeed if you assume
something about the marginal
distribution for example if you assume
it's Gaussian then this strategy will
work and what we're going to assume is
that the marginal distribution is hyper
contractive Jerry also alluded to these
distributions in the morning he called
them you know I think bounded where are
you Jerry what did you call them bounded
explicitly bounded okay and as you
mentioned they capture a lot of
interesting distributions for example
law concave distributions all product
distributions gaussians non spherical
gaussians even which is kind of
interesting and so what we prove is the
basically the following simple
structural lemma and is that if you have
two distributions D 1 and D 2 and
they're total variation distance is
bounded by ADA and then let's so imagine
that d to imagine that d 2 is uniform on
s prime okay your corrupted set and
imagine that D 1 is uniform on s your
uncorrupted set so we prove this
inequality what is this inequality
saying well you find some W prime let's
say by a brute-force search or whatnot
that has small square loss with respect
to D 2 that's the one you found from
brute force search this inequality says
actually that linear function that you
found really it's not doing so bad with
respect to the uncorrupted distribution
D 1 the the sample uniform on the
samples that were uncorrupted either if
that's the case then I'm in good shape
because I can apply some sort of
generalization bound for deep for for W
prime that I find and I'll know that
it's good with respect to the original
true distribution that I was looking for
and one nice thing about this this
little lemma that we prove is that the
proof is simple enough to be into
encoded into something called a sum of
squares proof system
questions about the statement in the
funny
oh yeah that was that I had that that
fourth power of L inner product X so
that's basically the dot-dot-dot
okay so I want to prove this to you
and as I said think of d1 is uniform on
the uncorrupted set d2 is uniform on the
corrupted set we have our bound on the
total variation distance and now I'm
going to slightly shift shift change the
game on you a little bit instead of
square loss I'm going to look at
absolute loss I'm going to prove the
lemma for you for absolute loss because
the proof is even easier than square
loss and when I do this I also need a
bound on the condition number of D 1 so
that's Kappa so that's the condition
number of the true covariance matrix for
D 1 for square loss I don't need about
this bound Kappa but for absolute loss
you do need this bound Kappa but I
wanted to prove it to you for absolute
loss okay and so remember I want to just
relate the air D to of L to the air of
do you want to go
okay so the proof starts off like this
since the total variation distance of D
1 and D 2 is at most a de then I know
that there's a coupling G on this joint
distribution X Y cross x prime y prime
so XY these are drawn you can think of
these as being drawn from D 1 and X
prime Y Prime
they're being drawn from D 2 and the
coupling if you're familiar with this
has the following nice properties the
marginal so G is a distribution and it's
marginal on XY is actually equal to D 1
its marginal on X prime Y prime is equal
to D 2 and the probability when I sample
from G that I get XY that's not equal to
X prime Y prime that's at most a de ok
I've seen total variation distance
defined this way so there's nothing deep
going on here but we need this coupling
this is how we're going to relate the
error from d1 to d2
okay so now I want to show you you know
this this lemma this robust certified
building lemma who wants to see me prove
it like in you know in real time I might
on my iPad okay okay good all right let
me make sure I have the right pen okay
yeah right so we have T V t1 t2 is it
most data that's good okay so what I
want I want to understand expectation
with respect to D one of Y minus L inner
product X the absolute loss yeah this is
what I want to bound but I want to bound
it in terms of something with respect to
D 2 so my first move here is going to be
to use the coupling okay so this is the
expectation of the indicator function X
y equals x prime y prime times the
absolute value y LX
and then the other case is that X Y does
not equal
x prime y prime x y- LX
okay
so far I think this is pretty good now
so I haven't I haven't screwed it up yet
so I have these two terms okay let's
look at the first term I'm going to
claim that the first term is less than
or equal to the expectation with respect
to d2 now so this is d 2y minus L inner
product X why is that well in this in
this first term X y equals x prime y
prime so you know when I have a d2 here
I have X prime Y Prime
and there are some terms that won't
contribute to this absolute loss those
are the ones where X Y does not equal X
prime Y Prime and that's why I have an
inequality okay so this first term
really is just the error with respect to
d2 there we've shifted to the air with
respect to d2 did that make sense okay
good now I have this other term and I'm
going to apply Koshi Schwarz so I'm
going to get square root of expectation
of G X Y not equal to X prime Y Prime
square times square root whoops
square-root expectation of d1y - Elinor
product X 180 squared it why did we get
to move to d1 well x and y you know
those are the variables that are drawn
from d1 so instead of G I now I'm only
concerned with with withdraws from d1
and this square here the square root so
this term in here is a de because that
was the fraction of points that the
adversary corrupted I mean that's the
statistical I mean that's that sorry
that's the total variation distance so I
get a square root of ADA and then this
term expectation of Y minus LX squared I
can just bound this by twice the
expectation of Y squared plus twice the
expectation of LX squared
and then remember L star was my optimal
linear function and we said the norm of
L was smaller than the norm of L star so
this term is at most two times Kappa
times expectation D one L star x squared
okay so so we're done we did it you know
here's here's the left-hand side this is
what we wanted to bound we said that the
air with respect to the uncorrupted
distribution is that most the air with
respect to the corrupted distribution
plus square root of ADA and the square
root of ADA gets multiplied by to
expectation of Y squared and to Kappa
expectation from deep misses this is
sort of like your opt this is like two
Kappa times opt with respect to square
loss okay Kappa was the condition number
of the covariance matrix for the
original distribution okay so I have L
inner product X here and that's at most
L star times Kappa because the norm of L
is at most the norm of L star
okay so we called this a robust certify
ability lemma two things to note were
that the only real inequality that we
used here was the Koshi Schwarz
inequality and also you see that you
have sort of squares of linear forms you
might want to remember that basically
there's nothing more than comparisons of
you know relatively low degree
polynomials going on here in this
inequalities are stones about this
robust yes not yet no so interestingly
for the absolute loss case I don't need
to use hyper contractivity but I do need
to depend on this condition number of
the distribution there's no fourth
moment here right I could use one to
hyper-connectivity at that one right
okay so for square loss if you want if
you want to see what happens for square
loss then I need to assume that instead
of a condition number on do you want to
going to assume that it's hyper
contractive that's a fancy way of saying
that I can bound its fourth moment in
terms of some constant times its second
moment squared okay and the the actual
statement that you get will be similar
to the one that we got for the absolute
loss this time I'm going to bound the
square loss and there's that square root
of ADA coming in again I have a hyper
contractivity constant this is my opt
and then I get again the hyper
contractivity constant square root of
beta and this sort of annoying fourth
power sitting there and you can see it
if you wanted to prove it for square
loss you would use the same approach for
absolute loss but so we would do the
same thing that we did here but instead
of a square root of expectation of y
minus L of x squared if we're starting
with square loss you end up with a four
here so then I have fourth moments and
so then I need to bound everything using
hyper contractivity in terms of the
second moments
okay so that's why absolute loss was
nice I didn't need to go to the fourth
moment if you want it you know robust
certifiable if you want the same lemma
for l2 for square loss then I do need to
worry about fourth moments and so I have
to use these hyper contractive
inequalities one thing to point out is
and I don't want to hide this is that we
do need you know if you look through the
proof you do need that two times the
hyper contractivity constant times
square root of ADA is at most one so you
need this sort of technical condition on
ADA the remember ADA is the amount of
noise and adversaries allowed to corrupt
and when when the distribution is
Gaussian
it turns out that ADA is something like
0.2 okay so as long as the fraction of
errors that the adversary corrupts is
less than like 1/4 there'll be no
problems with this proof but depending
on the district the you know what the
marginal distribution is for D 1 you may
have you know different tolerances for
different parameters of ADA okay so this
basically tells us that you know this
gives you this shirt this proves to you
that the brute-force search algorithm
works as long as you make these
assumptions on the marginal distribution
for D 1 now we want to come up with a
polynomial time algorithm how are we
going to do that much the same way that
Gerry did it in his talk we're going to
appeal to the sum of squares proof
system and do a non-convex relaxation to
find the subset that we're looking for
so so so let me try and show you how
this works without resorting to Marlies
theorem okay I'll say as much as I can
ok so let me actually show you what the
non-convex program is and then you can
imagine how you would relax it so what's
the non-convex program so it's a system
of polynomial inequalities so remember
that just to set this up you I and VI
those are going to be our corrupted
points and then our non-convex program
is going to have the following variables
it's gonna have W the WS are going to be
used to select that subset remember when
we were brute force searching through
subsets now we don't want to do brute
force search anymore but we somehow want
to select a good subset l is a set of
variables corresponding to the linear
function that we're looking for and then
we're actually going to have these other
variables X I prime Y prime those are
again enforcing that we're actually
choosing elements from our corrupted set
okay so yeah Rd
oh sorry sorry you're right sorry thank
you
so the objective function
it's going to be one over n
this is what we're trying to minimize
and then I'm going to have the following
constraints
some of the Wis is going to be at least
four minus eight times and
so the weights are going to select the
point so they should be at least of 1
minus a 2 times n that I would have W I
squared equals WI WI times UI minus X
that's why I
so every time so WI squared equals WI
enforces that WI is either 0 or 1 and
every time that WI is 1 it means that
you're selecting UI every time WI is 1
for one of these X I prime constraints
you're selecting a UI and every time
that WI is one for one of these VI
constraints it means you're these Y
prime constraints that means you're
selecting a VI so we could write this
program you know if we're still not
interested in polynomial time we could
solve the program we can come up with a
linear function a set of weights a set
of points from our from our corrupted
set and that would correspond precisely
to a subset that we're searching for and
furthermore the subset that we're
searching for is large so the uniform
distribution over that subset is going
to have small variation distance with
respect to the uniform distribution on
the original corrupted set and so we can
apply one of those robust certify
ability limits okay good this is the
program okay so now I'm going to make
the problem even harder instead of
actually searching for a linear function
I'm going to search for a distribution
over feasible solutions to this non
convex program so for example so this is
this is a harder problem because I could
find some distribution whose support is
only on the feasible points of that
original non convex program but you know
I'm just going to ask I'm going to
demand that we find some distribution on
them okay and I'm going to demand
furthermore that you know if you take if
you sample a solution from this
distribution mu this quantity the
objective function is minimized a soar
constraints are going to be satisfied
and we're going to minimize our
objective so right so this problem is
even harder so there's no polynomial
time algorithm to do it but instead if
you look at a relaxation of this program
and you this is part of the sum of
squares methodology instead of you you
actually can compute something called a
pseudo distribution it's not a real
distribution on on
feasible points on your non-convex
program it's something else it has the
following properties
so what properties does a pseudo
distribution have well like a normal
probability distribution it sums to 1
okay good and the sum of this
distribution times f of x squared for
any low degree polynomial F must be
greater than zero and if this is so you
know more technically if it's the case
that your pseudo distribution is
positive times any polynomial f of
degree L over two then we say that D is
a level L pseudo distribution and this
pseudo distribution can actually be
computed and time n to the order L so
one thing to notice is that if I took L
to be infinity then all of my elements D
of X would be positive and it really
would be a probability distribution but
it's not I'm getting some relaxed
version of a probability probability
distribution ok so right so what to
summarize what does this mean so instead
of solving for lwx i prime and y i prime
instead I'm going to compute their
pseudo expectations
I can't even so I wanted to compute
their expectations instead I'm computing
their pseudo expectations which I'm
denoting eat wittle Mew twiddle of L and
one thing to note is that this value is
actually a vector in R to the D okay
when I compute these pseudo expectations
of level L not only can I get the first
moment second moment and so on and so
forth I can get the elf moment pseudo a
moment of all of these variables here
all I'm going to need is the first
moment the first pseudo moment of this
variable L this is a vector in R to the
D and this is actually going to be this
is my solution that I'm going to output
okay so the linear function you know the
polynomial time algorithm is
to compute this pseudo expectation and
then output this pseudo expectation with
respect to MU twiddle of L that's going
to be my linear function that actually
output that's going to be the algorithm
any questions on this before I keep
diving into the analysis
okay so my crude some my crude summary
about pseudo expectations is that in
always they behave like real
expectations with respect to any
inequalities that involve low degree
polynomials okay so if you have an
inequality that involves degree three
polynomial x' and you've computed a
level four pseudo distribution you know
it's sort of a plug right into those
Paula will fool those polynomial
inequalities the polynomial inequalities
won't know the difference between you
know true optimal solutions true
feasible distributions and pseudo
distributions it's unable to distinguish
them let me yeah oh that's I have five
minutes okay so let me just show you how
we actually apply this in our context
yeah I'm gonna make it more rigorous in
just a second it's it's it's fairly
rigorous it's as rigorous as Marlies
they're slightly more rigorous than more
these do okay so I just have one slide
on how we actually apply this so
remember that
I'm calling opt SOS that was the minimum
value that was the optimal value of that
objective when we took the SDP
relaxation and it's definitely the error
of Optus opt SOS is definitely less than
or equal to the opt of the best fitting
linear function because the best fitting
linear function is a feasible solution
to that program and then I'm calling opt
for this annoying fourth moment term and
what we know what we proved you remember
when I excitingly proved the robust
certify ability for square loss or
absolute loss we actually proved was
this inequality but as you can see this
inequality as we mentioned only involves
degree for polynomials in fact it apply
it involved applying of Cauchy Schwarz
inequality and so you know some degree
to or some degree for polynomials popped
up but that's essentially all that
really happened okay
so by my crude you know understanding of
pseudo expectations that I mentioned on
the previous slide if instead of
remember we proved this for linear
functions turns out you can also prove
it for pseudo distributions okay so
instead of L here I can get expectation
sorry
err d1l on the left-hand side and then
on the right-hand side when I plug in my
pseudo expectation I'll get opt SOS here
and this stays as opt for and now I can
apply convexity and I'll get the air
respect to d1 I'll push the pseudo
expectation inside is it most this Plus
this but remember as I mentioned this is
actually a vector so it's a linear
function so what we showed is that the
air with respect to D 1 of this pseudo
expectation for L is actually at most
this factor times opt SOS plus the
fourth the opposite for here okay so
this is actually how we can relate the
pseudo expectation to the optimal air
from the original distribution
okay so it's plugging in the pseudo
expectation and using convexity
okay so just to summarize we don't solve
a non-convex program we only get a
pseudo distribution on the solutions but
these pseudo expectations obey our
inequalities and so by applying
convexity we can argue using that sort
of Phi ability lemma that this quantity
is indeed the linear function that we're
looking for okay so just a couple of
extensions everything that I've said you
know also works for higher degree
polynomial regression although now you
have to use some tools on hyper
contractivity of polynomials with
respect to these distributions it works
for all certifiably hyper contractive
distributions and in the paper we have
an application for learning boolean
functions which is a problem I'm very
interested in with respect to this nasty
noise model alias and Daniel and
Alistair have a recent paper on this but
I put a question mark here because we
need the error rate ADA to be so small
for our results on nasty noise with
respect to boolean functions that I'm
not sure they really capture interesting
classes of boolean function learning so
I think it would be interesting to to
extend extend this type of work for
boolean functions so I think I'll stop
here
[Applause]
questions
so another like measure they're not like
how much and post-op they're like how
much I give for an expectation in the
prediction of the off like basketball I
guess they are like Elinor product or a
low you know x- all starve Excel is
weird
sure yeah because that's like a smaller
value there you'll need to start
assuming things about the yes condition
number of the covariance ninjas
you get six of the nearish
sublinear was it like you know that
better like the quantity you haven't
picked up that you have this going to be
roughly like and tracing the scale as
you take more samples you know the
attitude should be nice to be on
constant I I don't know that's an
interesting question
other questions
so having basically excavated I'm
algorithms so there were some notions in
the literature or regression that's like
a generalization of the to keep depth to
version these might be precursors are
very like robust independence of time
this may be no I worked them out for s
general distribution but certainly for
the Gaussian whatever aviv-jaffa results
these are just information see already
oh okay thanks
the questions